9 on en vient à la guerre en Ukraine le
conflit entre dans son 9e mois en
l'absence de bilan officiel les Nations
Unies avancent un chiffre plus de 6300
civils auraient été tués et les catons
se poursuit puisque il y a eu sept morts
ce lundi à backmouth dans la région de
Donetsk depuis plusieurs semaines les
combats sont intenses dans cette zone à
noter aussi une force détonation à
souffler un bâtiment de la presse à
melithopole ville occupée par les Russes
dans le sud-est 5 personnes là-bas ont
été légèrement blessées bonjour Pascal
Boniface et merci de répondre à nos
questions vous êtes directeur et
fondateur de l'Institut de relations
internationales et stratégiques Lyris on
l'attend à un nouveau discours de
Poutine va-t-il réitérer ses accusations
puisque les Russes estiment que les
Ukrainiens préparent une bombe sale
c'est agir un engin explosif mais qui
contient une substance radioactive cette
histoire ces accusations de bons sales
ça cache quoi selon vous est-ce que
Moscou de masquer sa défaite sur le
terrain oui effectivement sur le point
de vue militaire et sur la défensive et
même retrait et donc on voit qu'ils
évacuent une ville et qu'ils ont perdu
du terrain et donc ils essaient de
reprendre l'avantage de deux façons à la
fois par des destructions relativement
importantes d'infrastructures civile
pour frapper au plus dur la population
ukrainienne et puis par cette menace
d'escalade puisque l'accusation menée
contre l'Ukraine de pouvoir guider une
bombe sale n'est que le l'épi phénomènes
pour dire nous pourrons réagir de façon
plus importante donc c'est un message
qui est envoyé aux alliés de l'Ukraine
pour dire qu'il y a un risque d'escalade
et que la Russie est prête finalement à
aller plus loin qu'elle n'a été pour le
moment est-ce que c'est un message aussi
destiné à la population russe pour
détourner l'attention
oui non il s'agit de faire peur pour
montrer que fort heureusement il y a des
dirigeants comme Poutine qui protègent
la population russe et au moment où la
population russe commence à douter pour
notamment ceux qui doivent être
mobilisés au moment où la population
russe commence à douter du bien fonder
de cette soi-disant opération spéciale
militaire qui normalement c'était une
opération spéciale militaire elle
n'aurait pas eu besoin d'une
mobilisation c'est une façon de faire
grossir la menace pour remobiliser
autour du pouvoir la population russe ça
pourrait servir de prétexte ce que vous
disiez en quelque sorte de prétexte à la
Russie pour qu'elle passe elle-même à
l'acte qu'elle utilise ses bombes sales
c'est ce qu'au cralotant en fait
alors là il y a un double risque si
l'Ukraine utilisait une bombe sale elle
se priverait du soutien des opinions
publiques occidentales et les
Occidentaux auraient plus de mal à
soutenir l'Ukraine et en même temps si
la Russie utilisait le même type d'arbre
ou des armes chimiques ou des armes
nucléaires Fustel tactiques elles se
couperait du monde non occidental qui
pour l'instant n'a pas renoncé avoir des
relations donc il y a un peu quelque
part retenez-moi au je fais un malheur
on essaye de faire peur mais si la
Russie utilisait ce type d'armes il
n'est pas certain que l'avantage
militaire serait déterminant par contre
le coût politique serait très important
pour la Russie en tout cas les
Ukrainiens démentent préparer ce genre
de bombe il joue la transparence ils en
appellent même à la UEA le président
zellenski a invité une délégation de
l'Agence internationale de l'énergie
atomique c'est une preuve de bonne foi
en tout cas c'est une preuve de bonne
communication qu'on a toujours fait à
ski et m'ont appelé à les infections
internationales est une façon de dire
qu'on a rien à cacher de rassurer
l'opinion et de montrer sa bonne foi par
rapport effectivement à un pouvoir qui a
russe qui a une certaine habitude dans
le monde